this morning we are continuing our
partnership with Ted to highlight
individuals and ideas shaping our world
in our series ideas that matter
University of British Columbia professor
Elizabeth Dunn made headlines when she
co-authored the paper spending money on
others promotes happiness more than a
decade ago in her new TED talk posting
this morning Dunn says simply donating
to charity is not enough to feel these
benefits spending money helping others
doesn't necessarily promote happiness
instead it matters how we do it and if
we want people to give more we need to
subvert the way we think about
charitable giving Elizabeth Dunn is here
now I can't wait to get to this idea
that subversion how should we give well
what we've seen our work is that you're
likely to get this the biggest emotional
boost from giving to others if you can
do so in a way where you really get to
see the impact that your generosity is
having and you feel a sense of
connection with the people or cause that
you're helping explain the transaction
the psychological transaction that
happens that creates this happiness
response to giving well I think this
sort of warm glow we get from giving is
actually built into human nature so
human beings have evolved to experience
joy from giving because actually our
survival really depends on our
willingness to make some sacrifices
along the way to help each other out
yeah you actually say we're wired to
given in your TED talk you said giving
to charities made about the same
difference for happiness as having twice
as much income explain please well so
this was based on Gallup World poll data
collected in countries around the world
and we were really pretty surprised to
see the magnitude of this effect that's
so consistently in every major region of
the world people who give money to
charity are happier than those who do
not even after taking into account their
own financial situation you know even
though you study the connection between
happiness and giving I understand you
weren't doing much of it yourself yes
this is something I chose to admit to
the world I'm a tedster
with the refugee program and how did
that change things for you yeah so I
hadn't ever really
found a cause that I felt deeply
connected with until the Syrian refugee
crisis and and at that time I learned
about an amazing private sponsorship
program that Canada offers where
essentially any five Canadians can
sponsor a family of refugees and you
have to raise enough money to support
them for their first year and then they
actually get on a plane to your city and
then you're in charge of helping them
settle in and helping take care of them
does it matter who you give to what are
you happy if you give to a stranger to a
family member or a friend he's going
through a hard time
we've seen in our research that in
general people are people tend to get
more happiness from giving to people
that they're close to as opposed to say
strangers or acquaintances but it
doesn't have to be that way right so you
know if you give to your niece and you
can see that she's so happy with this
basketball you just gave her and you go
out and play with her I mean of course
that's gonna give you this great
emotional boost I think the really
interesting challenge is how do we
harness that joy of giving that
impactful joy of giving and translate it
into charitable giving to help people
say on the other side of the world do
you need a baseline of empathy in order
for this to work or or if somebody's out
there saying like wait a minute if I
write a check that's not gonna make me
feel any better I mean do you need to
already have sort of empathy receptors
in order for this effect to take place I
mean I think most of us do my former
student Lera Ackman has shown that even
people who have been convicted of
felonies show this same effect so you
know even these ex-offenders who at
first glance we might think oh they're
not gonna be likely to experience joy
from giving others they show the effect
- so the point that we're seeing is that
really this is something that probably
all of us are capable of feeling
Elizabeth I can hear you know people
saying I would love to give more but I'm
barely making ends meeting myself does
it have to be financial in order
experience the same type of joy and
happiness there is also evidence that
spending time helping others can make a
difference for our happiness but we see
in our work with money that you know you
don't have to be Bill Gates you don't
have to be giving a giant amount of
money right even in our work we've seen
that giving as little as five dollars to
help somebody else can actually give you
this detectable boost that you feel
throughout the day all right Elizabeth
Dunn thank you for giving us a detective
to watch professor Dunn's full TED talk
visit our website at CBS this morning
dot-com